I don't remember how I first came out to
but I remember being at a holiday party
my freshman year of college that was the
fall of 96 at NYU and this girl said
you're gay and I was like no no she's
like honey please they're gonna come out
you're gay I'm like okay I'm gay and
then I realized you know what
it's no big deal I went to the Tisch
School of the Arts practically every
other person there was gay
absolutely nobody ever forces anyone to
come out
nobody ever outs anyone even though
people accuse me of that I report on
celebrities I report on the private
lives of public figures look at someone
like Anderson Cooper who even out
magazine has reported as being gay has
Anderson come out no that's his choice
he's choosing to remain in the closet
even though everybody knows he's gay and
that's okay because it's his story to
tell if and when he's ready but that
doesn't mean that the gay media myself
included shouldn't talk about Anderson
Cooper being in the closet and we
shouldn't talk about how much better it
would be for the community and for him
if he were open
it would be infinitely better for the
community if Anderson Cooper came out if
Kevin Spacey came out if Jodie Foster
came out why because visibility is key
the more straight people see that they
are gay folks out there the easier it is
for us to achieve change the easier it
will be for us to get marriage equality
the harder it is for people to hate